merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
partager avec les collègues ici présents
et les membres du gouvernement le
malaise que m'inspire le débat public
depuis quelques jours il y a une semaine
un jeune garçon a été tué par un
policier dans l'exercice des fonctions
policiers mis en Suisse en examen pour
homme ici volontaire et aujourd'hui le
procès qu'instruise certains politiques
et les médias c'est celui des quartiers
prioritaires et des parents qui vivent
nous assistons à une véritable
manipulation fondée sur une part de
mensonges et beaucoup d'ignorance
j'espère non les quartiers prioritaires
ne sont pas inondés de subventions
publiques payées par des bons Français
méritants 6100 euros 6000 100 par
habitant par an dans les quartiers
prioritaires 6800 dans les autres
quartiers dans ces quartiers dans
certains immeubles 40% de mer mono
parental qui enchaîne deux ou trois
boulots par jour qui gardent les enfants
des autres les nôtres souvent et qui ne
peuvent pas faire garder les eaux les
leurs des pères évaporées vous voulez
les poursuivre je suis d'accord avec
vous poursuivons-les utilisons ce qui
existe poursuivons-les pour abandon de
famille par exemple et dans les familles
ou les personnes présents vous vous
intéressez à la violence des enfants
intéressons-nous aussi à la violence que
ces enfants ont subi chez eux avec leur
mère et leur père alors madame la
Première ministre aujourd'hui au lieu de
laisser accuser les mers je vous propose
de les aider à survivre à vivre que nous
soutenions leurs associations que nous
les écoutions que nous les émancipions
du clientélisme municipal aussi mise en
sur les mers pour remettre les quartiers
d'aplomb ce serait probablement notre
meilleur investissement
[Musique]